what I'm about to say is going to piss
off a lot of people hijab is a symbol of
Oppression hijab is is one of the main
pillars of this Foundation of this
Islamic Republic and it's been
completely broken this is a huge blow to
the Islamic Republic this is only the
beginning of a much much bigger movement
in my opinion
hey everybody Welcome to My podcast I'm
Michaela Peterson I had King Rahm on my
podcast yesterday to discuss the Iranian
protests that are going on right now
because a 22 year old girl named Masa
was killed because her hair was showing
outside of her hijab
so I know in the west we have a couple
of narratives around the hijab and Islam
and you can be considered islamophobic
if you talk about how the hijab can be
oppressive but in a society where if
your hair is outside of it you can be
taken by the morality police and killed
that counts as oppressive so I had King
Rama on to discuss what it looks like in
Iran what people should know about
around the world and what people can do
to help so I hope you guys learned
something I hope the citizens win this
time
ROM welcome to my podcast
thank you for having me Michaela thank
you very much for coming on
um before we get started can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
um I'm a musician and podcaster I do
some acting I'm currently in Manchester
right now working on a theater project
um it's funny because I'm sort of known
as the Iranian Joe Rogan in this sort so
we'll talk about that later if you want
about my podcast and how it sort of
became a bigger sort of political and
cultural movement in itself but yeah
that's basically what I do
okay well thank you very much for
joining me um I wanted to cover the
protests in Iran and what's happening
um to learn more myself and because I
think that's something people worldwide
should know more about so we're going to
get into that so this is a more serious
topic today
um
could you could you describe for me what
is happening right now in Iran in
regards to the protests
yes absolutely
um and but just before I start I just
want to name if you don't mind several
of the people who have been killed in
the protests because sometimes I feel
like
you know these people they just turn
into another number another statistic
and it's it's so unfortunate because
these were people who had Lives who had
Ambitions who had dreams
and were just standing up for something
right something that they believed in so
if you don't mind I'm just going to name
a couple of the people who have been
killed so far we started off obviously
with Masa amini the first person who was
killed in this in this movement hanukio
Hadith
I mean who was only 16 years old
I mean the list goes on but I just I
just wanted to pay my respects to those
families and to send my condolences
um it's it's really terrifying what's
happening and I really appreciate
actually you actually that you that
you've had me as a guest on your show to
use this opportunity and this platform
to talk more about what's what's
happening right now because I think
it's it's important for the non-uh
Iranian audience to also understand
what's happening on the streets and why
it's important to their worlds as well
um and how sometimes there's this
misconception of oh it's not you know
there might it might be islamophobic to
talk about certain things or it's not
culturally appropriate but we'll get
into all of that but basically what
happened was Masa amini
what's this um young 22 year old student
from stock that's quarterstone Province
from a very you know
normal middle class
semi-traditional type of family who was
just visiting friends and family in
Tehran um on a holiday trip
and she gets pulled over
um in the car with her family and
mind you she only has like a little bit
of of a couple of strands of her hair
out it's not like some crazy very exotic
or over-the-top uh type of look that she
has it's a very very normal look
and the morality police you know take
her out and and arrest her on on charges
of of her bad hijab
and um while she's taken away to be
brief she's beaten really bad and
severely to the point where you know the
the photos later showed that she was
bleeding from her ears there was
congealed blood
and um she then while she's waiting to
be briefed at the Detention Center she
she apparently collapses and goes into a
coma and then dies two days later
and this is another crazy part of the
story that is that a journalist
um by the name of nulufar hamidi
happens to take a photo of her in her in
in her state of being in a coma
and that photo just goes viral and just
goes all across the nation and now the
same photographer who took that photo is
arrested this is it's this is how insane
it is like the way that the the Islamic
Republic of Iran is trying to cover
their tracks and the killing of this
innocent girl by first you know after
Mass I mean they've detained the
photographer now they're killing people
in the streets all to convince people
that they didn't kill her in the first
place you know it's just it's such a
messed up situation and
basically the death of maso has just
struck such a deep nerve with the entire
Society of people in Iran and people are
just absolutely outraged by your death
because this she represents everyone
she's just a normal person who wasn't
political she never tweeted anything
political she never wrote anything
political she didn't do anything in her
life came from a regular middle class
family no political affiliations
whatsoever and she died for nothing
and you know there's this I don't
remember who it was in World War II they
said first they came for the Socialists
then they came for the so and so in in
our country you know it's
after the 1979 Revolution you know the
at first
um the new government I promised that
they wouldn't enforce hijab
and um slowly they they it it crept into
their laws and and they just completely
banished you know this freedom of choice
for women to be able to choose whether
or not they want to wear the hijab and
with that came even more severe and
archaic laws against women
and I'm ashamed as a man in my society
and I think all men are because of the
fact of how easily we all became
hypnotized over the last 40 years and
how we allowed this sort of behavior
towards women to become so normalized
where they they completely lost their
freedom to choose what they want to wear
their freedom to to be able to leave the
country without their husband's
permission even an inheritance a woman
gets less than a man and so much more
like it's it's a joke like women have
zero rights and like they have some
rights but like compared to men they
have much less in Iran
and in Iran where the the sect of Islam
that we follow is Shia which we'll get
into a little bit later but basically I
just want to wrap up on this first part
about masa's death and this this tragedy
and how people have become outraged it's
a culmination of
of many years of frustration and
oppression starting mostly from like the
2009 green movement where Ahmadinejad
had stolen the election and people were
protesting demanding where their vote
went and it was a very peaceful uh sort
of protest and movement where there was
three million people in in the streets
in Tehran and it's it's such a majestic
photo when you look at the photos of
that time and they all were just
standing there in complete silence
like no one's saying a word no slogans
and even whatever slogans that existed
at the time were were very political a
couple years later there were then
protests that became more economic over
the price of eggs and gas and then 1500
people were killed in 2018
and so it's just like this culmination
of different movements and protests that
are happening
and eventually leading to this point
where Mass saw being killed is is just
people realizing that if we do not stand
against these oppressors now we're going
to live under this evil forever
I'm sorry if I went off I just no no no
no no no as thorough as possible it's a
difficult thing to talk about and I know
there's going to be a lot of things that
I say that's going to piss off both the
left and the right but I think it's
important that people hear our truth
about what's really going on
yeah yeah
um I'm not very familiar with what's
gone on in the last 40 years so I might
ask for clarification
um on a number of points and I think
people in my audience probably would
have similar questions so one thing is
what's the difference between the
government in Iran and other kind of
Muslim countries say say United Arab
Emirates how are they different so Iran
is I think one of the only two countries
in the world that is a theocracy it's
both it's Iran and the Vatican which are
led by a a a spiritual leader or cleric
or whatever the highest level of of
their religious Authority allows so in
case everyone is like the grand
Ayatollah in the Vatican it's it's the
Pope
and in in a theocracy the law is
directly connected to Divine Law and in
the in the absence of the Divine Law
the um the the highest religious
Authority has this this uh ability to
interpret the law as he sees fit
so it's it's it's it's
intertwined with with
um with with religion the the
Constitution and the the laws of the
land but in the in Saudi Arabia and UAE
it's more of a monarchy where
um Power is inherited and passed down so
the heir to the throne
Etc
um and and then that family decides to
to to enforce Islamic law so it's not
literally connected they don't believe
in the idea of that this is a Divine Law
that that is being enforced that is
directly
um interconnected within within our rule
oh that's one of the major differences
so like in Iran right now for example
the supreme leader as in the New York
Times just reported uh a week ago he's
in he's you know he's not in a very
stable condition he hasn't come out to
talk about the protest that he has
cancer he's dying
and this is one of the other reasons I
think the protests are still like in
this really strange State because it's
sparked it's people are no longer afraid
of this man of his shadow of his forces
there's especially the younger
generation they're absolutely Fearless
it's just incredible watching How brave
these kids are and
I mean the letters that I keep getting
every day the emails that the messages
that they send me is like you know what
these are these are kids who grew up
with the internet behind you too because
our generation as I was saying you know
is we grew up with so much fear Our
Generation we grew up with our parents
and our schools and our teachers
everybody telling us to not say that we
have alcohol in our home or we watch
foreign films or we do this or that
there was this constant orwellian sort
of surveillance happening at you at all
times
and I grew up in the city I grew up in
hippie Town Eugene Oregon you know and
then I moved back to Iran around like 10
years old and wow and one of the first
things I noticed was like this it was a
huge cultural shock for me because my
parents are very secular very old
liberal open-minded cool people and all
of a sudden like I have to learn to lie
from a young age and it becomes embedded
in your system to always like have to
live this double life of sorts
and I remember one day at school like
one of our teachers beat me up over a
Sony Walkman I was listening to music
and being the smart ass that I was I I
told them like I'm pretty sure that
Prophet you know never talked about a
Walkman in the Quran you know I'm sure
well yeah I got beat up some more ah so
you you learn really quickly of of of of
how like you know this this how messed
up this system is and but because the
the government and their security forces
and the Revolutionary guards Inspire so
much Terror
um that people just learned to live with
that fear but fear can only affect you
for so long as we see right now as a
point I'm trying to get to about this
this generation of kids of people who
are just who've had enough
you know when especially when you see
the woman burning their hijabs in the
streets standing in front of the forces
without their hijab this is like bravery
to the max I mean the courage that these
women have to stand defiantly in the
face of these security forces and give
zero [ __ ] and just be
um completely unafraid of losing it all
for what they believe in it's just I bow
down to them and it's just I feel so bad
that I'm not there with them and so the
least that we can do is to be their
voice is to is to amplify their voices
and to share their message with the
world because it's this is hijab is like
the is one of the main pillars of this
Foundation of this Islamic Republic and
it's been completely broken this is a
huge blow to the Islamic Republic and
this is only the beginning
um of of a much much bigger movement in
my opinion
uh
I read online that one of the things
that have happened in the last number of
weeks was the internet was cut off
so can you talk about what happened
there and is that still the case are
people able to access the internet so
they continue to cut off the internet
usually between like
like the hours of like four and six to
like later like midnight and later
um because it's easier to to control the
masses and it prevents them from
communicating with one another to to
organize because any any form that um
that that the people can become more
mobilized and organize is a is a threat
to them so they're they're trying
everything they can to circumvent that
type of mobilization and they're getting
tired this is one thing that people
don't notice like the security force a
lot of them they don't like some of them
are sadistic crazy fundamentalist type
people a lot of them are just normal
people who are being paid like minimum
wage to go and beat their fellow
citizens who don't want to do it
and but they're so terrified they're so
afraid if they don't what will happen to
them
and that's why you know you have uh this
whole topic around Elon Musk and
starlink yeah and how they're trying to
activate that everyone but there's still
like logistical problems of how to get
these terminals to Iran because
um the the U.S Secretary of State I
think uh blinken uh they they sort of
said that Elon can't activate Starling
for Iran it can go around the sanctions
and and all that sort of international
law and the causes that existed but the
problem now is the logistics of how do
you get all these thousands of terminals
to the people over there so they can
have free access to information because
in Iran we do not have freedom of press
we don't have Freedom of Information and
without that it's it's very difficult
for the people to to share and spread
their news to and and their truths more
importantly to see what's happening to
them so that's why
it's so effective when people with their
mobile phones they come and film
everything I mean I'm sure you've read
about masi alinejad a prominent Iranian
um
feminist and uh activist who who has
started this very incredible movement
called the white Wednesdays and my
stealthy Freedom you know inspiring a
generation of women to take off their
scarves and very peacefully just take
off their scarves you know stand in the
street or film themselves and this has
been met with an insane amount of uh
aggression and repression from the
regime and they've arrested many of the
woman who who have con who have been
active in these sort of uh activities
and not only that but they're so afraid
of Messi she's become sort of the
Achilles heel like it's it's amazing
that you know one woman has has been
come such a thorn in the side of this
regime that they've sent two assassins
on American soil to kill her wow
and that's something that that is just
insane and and I'm familiar with that
because I've been threatened many times
too I mean just to give a quick
parenthesis about my story is my father
was in environmental activist and
professor
who was killed in an Iranian prison only
a few years ago oh and when we went back
to try to get my mom out of the country
my mom was arrested at the hospital I
mean at the airport and she was held
hostage for two years until we got her
out
I have to go on like gosh so so I'm very
familiar about the the the the the the
repressive tactics of this regime how
they use their propaganda how they play
on the sentiments of
you know the the nationalistic
sentiments of their own people
in order to to sort of say oh look you
know the West is trying to divide and
conquer us which is [ __ ] you know
people are more united than ever against
this oppressive Force this this
Leviathan that has been over you know
overseeing our people and terrorizing
our people for so long people I mean the
breaking of this the pillar of hijab is
the first step of of people inching
closer and closer to complete freedom
but it's in the nature of these
autocratic regimes where they just don't
give up and they double down every time
they've had so many opportunities to
make things right but they just can't
help themselves you know that's that's
the craziest part and it's
um the level of violence that they are
willing to use in order to to prove that
they're you know that they're a great
government or they don't kill people or
all these other things which are just
more essentially just to stay in power
it's something that I think a lot of
non-iranian people in the west really do
not comprehend or understand and this is
something that bothers a lot of us
because you see people
coming and speaking about hijab in a way
as if it's a choice it's not a choice in
Iran in Iran under Islamic Sharia law in
the Shia sect I don't want to speak on
behalf of all Muslims I know what I'm
about to say is going to piss off a lot
of people hijab is a symbol of
Oppression in our country okay
and what the people want is for them to
have the choice to whether or not they
want to have the hijab or to dress
however the however they want to I'm
sorry I don't want to swear on the show
um
it's it's it's such a fundamental issue
that has completely terrified the regime
that and now when the women are
protesting the street even now when
they're walking around the day without
their hijab like the the police like
don't have the balls to do anything to
them anymore this is like it's amazing
how the and and it's very sad because
the death of Masa amini is is wasn't the
first
there have been many people who have
died at the hands of this regime my
father included so many people have died
at this hand of the dream for the ideals
of a better tomorrow of a better future
of a better country
and she won't be the last either
unfortunately
but it's it's brought people to this
point of realization
that what we want and what our demands
and desires are are much bigger than
this it's not about just now that we get
rid of like mandatory hijab it's going
to be much much bigger because
people have realized that if we give in
to this oppression we're going to have
to live under this shadow of evil for
the rest of our lives and to my Western
friends you know I mean I I consider
myself to be like super Progressive and
liberal about everything I mean the idea
is that I don't really care what you
wear or how you wear it but but and I
understand the historical implications
of of colonialism of imperialism of how
certain miscalculations by the American
government the British government and
other European governments have caused
Enrique so much havoc in the Middle East
no one is denying that I understand all
of that but when I see people like I'm
looking at you code pink and other
similar like woke groups who cuddle up
to these vicious monsters and try to
paint them in a picture where they're
peaceful people with a different culture
that's absolute [ __ ] that's absolute
[ __ ]
okay and people want me to say this so
the rest of the world can hear this
don't use this as an excuse and I'm not
and I'm not being islamophobic I'm not
I'm not even though I deeply dislike all
religion I'm not a fan of religion but I
respect everybody's right to believe in
what their faith they have the problem
is though with a lot of religions
specifically Islam is that this idea of
how they always want to enforce their
beliefs upon you especially on women
especially on women
and this is something that needs to be
addressed because if you know Masa amini
was our George Floyd moment
and what did George Floyd do it brought
so much awareness to the issues the
systematic racism and all these other
important issues that people need to
talk about and how to resolve them I
know there's a lot of and I know it's a
very divisive subject and I don't want
to get get into that but it's the same
idea of raising awareness it's good that
people have a conversation a healthy
conversation without being divisive but
to understand that the people in Iran
didn't especially the women do not have
the choice they they by law they they
they they're so far behind in terms of
the men so it's so when westerners
condone
and normalize that behavior it life
becomes much more difficult so if you
were a true feminist and you're not
speaking up right now against what's
happening in Iran you're a complete
hypocrite
sorry about that Rand
no no no this is this is serious it's
been
it's crazy to watch from the outside
just the clips that are going around on
Instagram and it's strange because I
haven't seen it covered very much and I
don't know if it's too soon but I feel
like I haven't seen it covered that much
which is strange given how large the
protests are I think there have been
protests across the world though I think
there was a protest in Toronto that's
where I'm from and I think people are
protesting everywhere do you think that
do you think that if enough people
protest and continue to protest in Iran
this is something that can change like
do they have enough do the citizens have
enough power to actually topple this
regime
you know there's a saying and there's a
Persian idiom that this camel will
finally you know sit at your door one
day
um like the black camel which represents
sort of like death of the Grim Reaper
people like I said we always lived in
this state of of of fear of this this
this normalized way of oh people are
suffering but as long as I make ends
meet everything is fine as long as it
doesn't happen to me
everything is fine
but it happens I never thought in a
million years it would happen to me Masa
I mean you never thought in a million
years it would happen to her
you know this this this is the thing
that that that that that that
photographer who took that photo who's
now in prison
sparked the movement and now she's what
what did she do wrong the only thing
that she did was revealing the truth the
same person I don't know if you remember
like the Iranians who shot down the
Ukrainian flight the PS 752
um a couple years back and
how they lied and denied everything
until the last moment when they finally
caved in it's
again that that moment the reason the ad
became revealed was because one person
happened to accidentally film the
shooting of the plane and he put it on
Twitter and that same guy got arrested
too for revealing the truth so you're
seeing a pattern here obviously it's
like if you speak the truth
you're going to get into trouble in this
in this Society
and
I think the worst case scenario
I hope not but even if if this time
this movement gets cracked down by the
government
worst case scenario they break in
free from they've broken free from the
shackles of hijab like hijab will be a
joke in our country from now on like
it's there's no way they're going to be
able to enforce it on this level anymore
that's like the worst case scenario
best case scenario if people stay United
this is like more of a
um a constitutional it's it's a battle
where they people need to to take their
time it's not something that's going to
happen overnight they need to be
consistent they need to tire out the
enemy because they're getting tired
they're running out of forces they're
bringing they're bringing security
forces from Hezbollah and Lebanon and
Syria to beat up their own people
uh okay so that means that they're
getting tired that means it's becoming
difficult for them and with the sort of
semi-conspiracy theory of of Harmony
whether he's dead or alive or what's
happening to him because if he does die
in the middle of all this that would
just be the spark that would ignite a an
entire crazy movement which
unfortunately I think will include a lot
of Bloodshed because there's going to be
a power vacuum when he dies in all the
different factions that are going to be
fighting for power we're going to try to
stay in that position so
as a cliche goes before it gets any
better it's going to get much much worse
uh you talked a bit about morality
police can you describe what the like
how long have those guys been around for
and what do they do the morality police
that sounds terrifying that sounds very
orwellian it is and it's it's you know
they're they're they've been around for
like four or five decades now and who
basically a semi-legal entity and who
who have this who according to this law
called amriba marouf's which translated
let me I've written this down because
the English translation
um it's a it says enjoying good and
forbidding wrong that's what the English
translation which basically means you
know the individual or Collective Duty
depending on Islamic school of to
intervene and enforce Islamic law so
what's what's the problem with this the
problem is is that some person
who has any resentment towards a woman
or man has some sort of psychological
issue or is is sexually repressed which
I think is it plays a big key in a lot
of the the the the the the the the the
reasons that psychologically push people
to commit these types of violence
against women
the whole idea
is that I'm interpreting the Divine Law
according to my grand Ayatollah
to to beat the living [ __ ] out of you to
make you do something right
it's it's I I don't people have watched
the handmaid's tale Iran is literally
Gilead
in its truest form like that is like a
uh you could just film the whole thing
in Iran it's the same thing Gilead is
like it's a real place and it's called
Iran
and the the problem is that you have
these kids it's all a lot of times like
some of these moral police or even young
kids you know who who are filled with
this rage and this anger
and for for not being accepted or loved
or whatever it is and to have to give
them that Authority that green light to
brutalize people to torture people
in all in the name of religion of
righting wrongs like it's so messed up
and it's so terrifying because the
regular police you can you can bribe you
can reason with them because you know
they're just like getting paid to do it
a shitty job they're easily you can
easily bribe them
but these moral police there's this part
of their brain that justifies their
their inherent violence and actions
because they believe
I think on some level that they're doing
the right thing maybe or they're just
really really messed up people
who unfortunately wield a ridiculous
amount of power
you know it's it's a very terrifying
notion and we've we've all faced those
type of police as kids in in Iran
and yeah how common is this is this like
are they walking around what does it
look like there in regards to morality
police or what's the risk too of being
arrested
so it it you know the the strange thing
is Iran has gone through phases of
conservative and reformist presidents
starting all the way from 1998 when
khatami first came to power
who promised a lot of reforms but was
unable to deliver on any of them
and then ahmadine was more conservative
came into Power you know he we saw what
he did how he killed the people and then
Rohani again another wolf in sheep's
clothing
is full on this is another thing I want
to say first of all kudos to Christian
amanpur who refused to put on a scarf to
interview her icy last week when he was
attaining the U.N General Assembly kudos
to her and shame on Leslie's dollar 60
minutes
for wearing a mask at the same time that
mass amini had been killed for that very
stupid symbol that was ridiculously
unacceptable she sits in front of the
man who is actually known to be on the
death committee which was a death
Committee of
four judges in 1988 that were
responsible for the massacre of 5 000
people this man is our president the
hangman the same guy who killed all
those people is our president and he
walks into the U.N talking about women's
rights
this is a [ __ ] joke like it's it's
absurd and the fact that people and
governments in the west allow this and
shake hands with them this is this
reminds me very much of the time when
people were appeasing to Hitler the more
that he had killed the more he invaded
like oh no he'll he's had enough you
know he won't do anything more this is
the exact same thing and what the West
doesn't realize and that I think they've
tried to but in a very inefficient and I
think a very incorrect way is that
if Iran becomes a free Society a free
country
and it creates more stability in the
Middle East
you won't have export of Terror you
won't have export of violence you won't
have all these negative things that are
coming from the country because Iranian
people are are are bright people they're
educated they're literate they're
they're passionate about their culture
and their history it's just so
unfortunate that we have become we've
been held hostage at the hands of these
monsters for the past 40 years you know
they're they're just uh unfortunately
there is a there is a and obviously
there is a a significant amount of
people who are religious in in the
country but that doesn't mean that the
necessarily fundamentalists in the same
view as the government or they don't
believe in the violence even a lot of
religious people are like just let the
woman choose if they want to have a
hijab or not
but the the violent minority of them
that oppose that idea that freedom
are willing to kill at any cost for this
simple Act of a woman just showing her
hair
you know it's it's terrifying honestly
no that is terrifying do you have
opinions on why politicians are just
people in the west have have kind of
gone along with this and said oh it's
okay
even the journalists wearing wearing a
hijab after what's happened do you have
any idea why people are doing that type
of thing in the West
I think it's a combination of this
um sort of
maybe new this is this is all subjective
personal yeah yeah this isn't anything
based in Factor science but if I if you
ask me I think it's it's a combination
of
of the the chaos of international
politics and how to deal with the
diplomacy between nation states
um there's a historical context of of
again how do we tiptoe around the
history that's been between the
countries and then there's the issue of
I think the socio-cultural issue of this
this new woke movement where
um I think people sort of misinterpret
another culture or people
um in a way that it's you know it's it's
very strange I think the way that um in
the west that that the people
um you know you have and it's very
beautiful you have people with hijab on
the cover of Vogue or whatever and
people you know speaking about you know
hijab uh being a symbol of power but
like I said it's in Iran it's not it's a
symbol of Oppression because women do
not have the ability to choose and I
would even argue that most most Muslim
women and all could probably get [ __ ] on
this but I think don't have the ability
to choose they're born into this I I if
if if it was up to me I would say once
you're 18 without the influence of your
family your culture your Society then
you choose you consciously choose that
okay I want to go to a mosque I want to
go to a church I want to go to a
synagogue I want to wear a scarf then I
would say yes it you have the freedom
and the maturity to choose that decision
but as a young girl who's who's taught
from a young age that you know
The Gaze of the man or the the opposite
sex is evil Etc like you should not be
ever shown in public and it's it's it
just creates I think this this negative
fear because
what happens around this whole idea is
that
I think people are trying to create it
in this cool like hip fashion way of of
of of empowerment which I totally
understand and like I said it's I have
no problems with people wearing their
job I don't care
but it's the people who normalize it in
countries like ours saying oh it's such
a beautiful thing blah blah it's not
women are do not want this women are
being oppressed by this and
until people realize this I don't think
we can really
like move forward with this conversation
because it's coming from this bubble in
the west where I don't think people have
a real comprehension of what it's like
to live under this immediate threat this
immediate fear of your life being in
danger if you if you're a couple strands
of your hair just fall out like yeah
that those are the real consequences
these are the real consequences that
we're seeing right now of people
who of normal people who who was wearing
her a job but because of a little bit of
it being off she was killed
so I don't know how anyone can still
come and talk on TV and say oh you know
it's not about hijab boss it's about
this or that no it is about hijab
how how common is it I think I I might
have touched on this a little bit but
how common is it for somebody to be
arrested for violating hijab laws like
are are people worried about it
constantly and really strict about it or
is no I mean the women right now are so
much more braver they really don't care
I mean it's it's but since I see the the
the the judge from the death committee
became president he brought in wait when
you call it death committee is that what
it's called or are you just calling it
that no that's what it's like commonly
known as between the people because of
how many people they killed it's it's
what it's still historically known as as
a death committee so this man who's our
president was on the deaf committee is
now enforcing again all these archaic
Islamic laws that have been you know
sort of this is the problem with the
with an autocratic system even those
supposed wolf in sheep's closing
reformists who tried to make things a
little bit better
claim to be moderates Etc
the very nature of an autocratic regime
you know is is in a way that it will
never bow down to its people's desires
and will only enforce what it feels is
only best for their vision of of of
society there's no winning in this
Society for us there's no winning you
know it's similar case in Russia and
other places too I think where there are
autocratic leaders
it's it's one of those problems that
I think people don't understand that
you're not dealing with a democracy
you're not dealing with a a a a a
president who is freely allowed to to
run and and like be elected in by their
people so I just wish that the West
would become more aware of this they
would they would inflict more
um uh tougher laws specifically like the
magnitc act magnitsky act which would
Target all these people who are on the
higher levels of the government and hurt
them in their pockets and put them on
no-fly zones and and just not allow them
in any way to be able to communicate
with the West because all these people
all they have it's what's what's really
messed up is they all all of their
relatives and their kids and stuff they
steal their billions of dollars and they
live in the West
and it's like if you if you love this
Gilead world so much why don't you just
stay there like what are you doing on
the other side of the planet I
understand why people immigrate normal
people immigrate because of a better
opportunity better finances and job but
these kids these Rich Kids of these
mullahs already have like billions of
dollars are now living in the west you
know it's it's and that's another thing
that furiates a lot of people
um
of of of of of how this is this this
hypocrisy that they have and they when
it comes to their own families they do
whatever they want but when it comes to
the people they they enforce these
extremely violent laws
yeah this is a crazy situation uh it's
crazy
it's hard to I I guess part of the
reason maybe people in the west have
misunderstood this is because it's hard
to imagine
I think a society like that for people
who haven't experienced it at all
um what can people do
who who yeah what can people do who
aren't in Iran
that's a good question because I think
raising awareness being on your show
having other like celebrity friends you
see everybody talking about this sharing
about this is this is our George Floyd
moment this is the moment where we need
the world we stood by you know
Ukraine we stood by George Floyd we
stood by Taiwan Hong Kong like we were
there when when all these events happen
and we need the world to be our voice
especially the voice of our woman the
voice of all these young girls who are
fighting in the street burning their
hijab I mean people have to realize the
amount of balls balls the courage It
Takes The Bravery it takes for these
girls to go and burn their hijab and
their scarves in front of the police in
their faces like you you don't really
understand like that's I I can't even
think of anything more Brave than that
it's insane and in order to be their
voice because we can't be beside them in
the streets like everybody in the world
has to speak up I mean
this is this is something that that
concerns everyone around the world you
know it's it's it's
and it's crazy because I saw today one
of my friends you know Christopher Ryan
who wrote sex at dawn
um yeah he posted some things like why
do old men from Texas to Tehran care so
much or afraid so much of the woman body
you know and and I think that's very
true I think regarding the also idea of
comparison between you know maybe
evangelicals in in the west and and the
extremist fundamental islamists in in
the in the east
but it's like the the the the the
woman's body has become a Battleground
you know they should have the autonomy
over their body they should have
complete control over their body and
if if we do not be their voice if we
don't share this news and and I
encourage everyone to reach out to as
many people as you can celebrities but
get someone to go on Rogan's show we
need someone on Joe's show to talk about
this we need we need the whole world to
be aware because if there are more
people watching if the more people are
raising their voices it's going to
become much much harder for the
government to keep cracking down and
killing its own people they know because
they they know that they're they're
taking their last breaths and if they
want to remain into power and and have
some sort of diploma diplomatic uh a
seat at the a diplomacy with the world
they're going to have to like lay back
down so
I urge all people to contact your local
Representatives email them ask them to
speak out contact celebrities famous
people actors podcasters let them know
to keep speaking out about it
influencers whatever because it
pressures because that normal person
who's wearing that that that that that
that police uniform and beating up his
own people right now he he has Instagram
too
he has Twitter and when he sees
his favorite football player
or basketball player or actress or
whatever says like
stop killing your own people
you know it it it it it may not have a
huge effect but even if it changes the
mind of one person to not kill his his
brothers or sisters and that day will
save one life
so it can be effective I mean look at
the highest people keep saying hashtags
are pointless they're stupid the Masa
amini hashtag has broken like all sorts
of Records it's across like 100 million
or something it's insane
I mean don't quote me on that number it
might have been 10 million I'm sorry I
don't know I don't know but I know it's
in the top five of ever like retweeted
the hashtag so
um
these things do have an effect and the
government does watch them they notice
these things no matter how violent they
are and the way that they react with
this type of violence also shows that
they're afraid it shows that they don't
know how to handle this situation and if
the world just keeps being the voice of
these young brave men and women who are
dying in the streets for a better future
I mean like I said in the beginning
these these kids when they write to me
they say I got beat up they send me all
these pictures of them being bruised or
hit by bullets and whatever and their
car windows Smash and like ROM I got
beat up today but you know what I'm
still gonna show up tomorrow as well
and I'm sitting here in my hotel room in
a comfortable AC Etc like what the [ __ ]
am I doing I just feel ashamed even
coming here I I just want to be able to
amplify their voice I just want to I
just want them to be heard their demands
even though maybe some of the things I
said today may be insensitive to some
maybe but it's important that they hear
what our truths are what the people's
demands are
it a better Iran is a is a more stable
and better Middle East and it's much
better for the whole world do you have
any suggestions for people who want to
learn more about this where they should
go where can they follow you as well we
should add that in there
um I'm sharing some stuff on my my
Instagram it's just King ROM um is a
great source uh I'll link that below
yeah
um and uh there are other channels and
and political pundits I can't I can't
think off the top of my head right now
at the moment Karim sad joke is another
good one um there are people who
um genuinely are are concerned about
what's going on and trying to it's so
hard to because the Islamic Republic of
Iran's propaganda arm is so good at
sort of just creating so much
disinformation and spreading false news
in order to sort of money the waters you
know false hashtags Etc so it's
sometimes hard to find like a trusted
Source that's that's the way that these
information will always sort of work
um in in today's world but
um just you know just just keep keep you
know it's it's a sort of cliche thing in
America but try to read news from all
sides you know don't just stick to CNN
or fox or MSNBC yeah because it's like
everybody has their own spin on the
stories as well too their type of guests
you know I you know unfortunately I've
seen a lot of you know people who come
and and say oh hijab is not that big of
a deal no it is that's that's it's it's
all about that and that's like the first
only step towards Freedom
um and and once this this pillar has
been broken which it already has I think
we move on to the next ones you know
freedom of press Freedom of Information
Etc and the freedom to to to to to to
choose whatever you want to be in a
society where it's just impossible to
live without the government meddling in
every single public and private sphere
of your life okay well thank you very
much for coming on
thank you so much for having me because
I really really appreciate the
opportunity